maintenant que l'europe va mieux on me
dit qu'il ne faut pas surcharger la
barque européenne mais il ne faut pas à
l'heure où nous sommes
péché par excès de prudence nous sommes
en train de réparer le toit de l'europe
mais aujourd'hui et demain nous devons
patiemment étage par étage moment après
moment inspiration après inspiration
continuer à ajouter de nouveaux étages à
la maison et rock
il faut parachever la maison europe
maintenant qu'il fait beau et tant qu'il
fait beau parce que quand les nuages se
formeront à l'horizon et ils vont se
former un jour il aura été trop tard
alors larguant les amarres line l'os
comme disent les âmes
mettons les voiles et profitons les bond
favorable
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]